they said you are the highest moneymaker
mafia boss out set up alpha point you
were making six to eight milliliter
aspired to be made
I was 17 years old when my dad drew a 50
year prison sentence my best friend was
walking in Philomath but the setup was
bad yeah I'll be honest what I might
have gotten killed so there's a lot of
people I sit down with and I meet but
Michael I have to tell you you're you're
one of the most fascinating people that
I've been looking forward to sitting
down with and you had Nicky eyes and
Mikey franchisee when you hear about the
modern day not even a modern day you
know the movie Godfather everybody has a
poster and you watch the movie and you
hear about Michael Corleone and you
think is there really a character like
that you pretty much are the real-life
Michael Corleone leaper say of that
story right so it's exciting to be
sitting out with you appreciate you for
making the time and welcoming us to your
place here well thank you and I have
been compared obviously to to Michael I
think it's a good comparison at times
because Al Pacino he played a terrific
role in that movie yeah and there is a
certain flow that I watch in the movie
with them and I see with you where the
mannerisms it's amazing how close that
is with the mannerisms that you have on
the way you speak so let's get right
into it if you don't know Michael
Franzese II let me give you some stats
here's the best way to open it up so
you'll know who we're sitting down with
so in 1986 Fortune magazine November
10th Fortune magazine there's an article
saying the 50 biggest mafia bosses right
and and when you go through this the
part in here that's fascinating to me is
the following they have you down on 18th
place right and then they had John Gotti
at 13 so you look at this and you say
well you're 18 Gotti is 13 and then you
have Anthony Salerno at first and you
have some of these other name Persico
Carmine Persico you work with very
closely for many years Salvatore Santoro
some of these names that people know
about the part that I looked at Michael
there is not a single person on this
list where there
starts with the number three except for
you gadi was 46
you were 35 so we're not just talking
about somebody who made it to the high
level of the Colombo family the five
families the Colombo family yourself you
did it at 35 years old how was it being
raised into that environment in that
family I would say I had a good role
model as far as you know my dad being a
real person of substance in that life
and you know I love my father he was he
was everything to me
growing up and you know he was an
important figure there and it's not that
I tried to emulate him Patrick because I
never thought I would be part of that
life growing up you know I had different
thoughts I was gonna you know I was an
athlete I was going to school I was
going to be a doctor but once I made a
decision to get into that life I had as
far as I was concerned the best guy in
the world to model myself after and that
was my dad I learned a lot from him
directly watching all the things that
was taking place yeah just the way he
carried himself you know the way people
respected him the respect that he had
for my mother and and my sisters and
just the way he carried himself you know
and he was a man's man and you know from
the time I was five years old my father
drummed it into my head you know Michael
you have to be a man's man that's the
standard in life you have to live up to
he in many ways form the person that
that I became later on in life yeah it's
so much street credit that you can tell
if somebody did something to you and
they knew who your dad was there was a
line like you couldn't mess with it how
was it being raised in that environment
well it was different you know I always
tell the story I was an athlete and
baseball was really my sport and my dad
would never miss a game no matter what
he was doing mob business legit business
I'd be playing ball he'd show up he'd
always come to the field late and he'd
pull up in a big black Cadillac or a
black Lake and he'd get out of the car
dressed sharp in a suit and he'd always
have five or six guys with him because
he never traveled alone and I'd be up to
bat and they'd walk out on the field the
umpire would take one look at him and
never call strike three on me so I mean
it had his advantages you know being
Sonny Franzese his son you know he he
was just a great father you know and
obviously I knew there was something
different about him but my dad never
spoke about it now
it's really never so you didn't really
know fully what was taking place never
from him I knew because he was such a
high-profile figure that we lived in an
environment where law enforcement was
around us all the time and he was under
surveillance from five or six different
agencies from the feds right down to all
the state and locals so they would Park
cause around our house and follow us
wherever we went and you know I viewed
them at that time as the enemy because I
viewed my dad is my hero and so I knew
who he was I obviously read the papers
he had a lot of press and I observed
things but never from his mouth he would
never bring it into the house for in the
house we were just the family that
didn't exist isn't that interesting yeah
door six areas I'd like to touch up on
here with you one is story on how that
life was to how the game because you
wrote a book I'll make you an offer you
cannot refuse the game between what you
have to experience now similar that is
on the corporate side I think there's a
lot to be learned from the entrepreneurs
who watch this I do how to identify
consigliere I really want to stay on
that because what it means to be a
conciliar II how do you identify that
it's a very fascinating way you talk
about it in the book human nature you
know how do you read through the BS and
how do you read through some people that
are trying to take advantage of you what
are some of the things that you saw and
then some side questions about
characters and then some fun questions
at the end I will go through so why
don't we get into it as far as when you
knew and you said I want to get in how
did you get into the whole you know
family I want to become a made man how
did that whole experience take place
with you you know Patrick I never
aspired to be a made man you know I was
on a different path in life but I was 17
years old when my dad drew a 50 year
prison sentence and went off to serve
his federal time and I sat with my dad I
visited him in the federal jail before
they shipped him off to the penitentiary
and he said to me Michael I'm innocent I
didn't commit this crime it was alleged
to have masterminded a nationwide string
of bank robberies he said I never knew
the witnesses I'm not a bank robber the
witnesses were all drug addicts junkies
and one thing
I knew my dad hated anything to do with
drugs my whole life he preached against
her he would make up stories about drug
addicts to scare me never to take drugs
so I knew he would never bother with
people like this so I believed him and
when he went away joe columbo the boss
of our family who we were close with he
kind of took me under his wing because
my dad was his underboss and I started
to meet a lot more of my dad's friends
you know and they were influencing me
Mike you know what are you doing going
to school I was a pre-med student at
that time shortly after that you know if
you don't help you father out he's gonna
die in prison so I went to see him in
Leavenworth and I said that I'm not
going to school you're gonna die in here
if I don't help he didn't want that I
mean he kind of argued no I want you to
go to school get an education I said
that's too late my mind is made up and
he said to me he said if you're gonna be
on the street then I want you on the
street the right way in his mind the
right way was to become a member of his
life and he proposed me at that point
for membership into the life and you
know the interesting thing Pat my father
even at that point never told me what
the life was about you know you're not
supposed to talk about that life with
anybody outside of it and he wouldn't
violate that policy even with me it's on
something my dad's a good soldier he
just said go home somebody would be in
touch with you do whatever you're told
it was kind of on the job training and
two weeks later I sat with the boss and
you know he ran things down for me and
told me what to expect and for the next
year and a half I was kind of a recruit
where I kind of learned the life had to
do anything I was told to do to prove
myself worthy and then Halloween night
1975 is one it was formally inducted
into that life you remembered vividly
vividly yeah and how was what was that
process like was there ritual was there
an experience you had to go through very
very solemn ceremony very serious six of
us walked into a room individually
towards midnight that night it was a
very secure setting obviously I walked
into a room the boss was seated ahead of
like a horseshoe configuration the
underboss in the console area to his
left and right and all of our capo
regimes are captains alongside of them
and I walk down the aisle stood in front
of the boss I held out my hand he took a
knife right here cut my finger some
blood dropped on the floor this is a
blood oath I cupped my hands he took a
picture of a saint Catholic called the
cod put it on my
and lit it aflame it didn't hurt it
burned quickly it was just symbolic
and he said tonight Michael Franzese you
are born again and to a new life until
the Cosa Nostra this thing of ours
violate what you know about this life
betray your brothers and you will die
and burn in hell like this st. is
burning in your hands do you accept yes
I do and that's it that's the ritual
that's wharton sweet but extremely
serious now there was six of you the six
of us we went in individually you take
it alone got it and then out of these
six apparently you're the only one
that's alive well they're they're all
dead not one of them died in natural
causes everyone in one murder
Wow so why are you still here you know
because if you if you read the story and
you you you put yourself out there and
it's not like you went and you ratted
people out or you became an informant
there's nothing there that people will
say even some of the guys that were
upset that you stepped away they don't
call you Informer they just say you know
it's impressive to see that he was able
to make it and we're proud of them even
some of your enemies are saying good
things about you what how did you how
was that process for you never hear
somebody serve on when they leave the
family how did that happen with you well
you know Patrick I don't I I didn't have
any grand plan because there's no
blueprint to walk away from that life
not enter a program and survive and you
know I'm only saying this because it's a
fact I don't know of anybody else that
has done that successfully especially at
the level that I reached because I was
at a pretty high level you know I didn't
know how it was gonna work out I knew
that when I walked away people are gonna
be upset you don't walk away from that
life you're not allowed to renounce it
and I had a lot of trouble as a result
but you know for me there's two sides of
this there's a spiritual side obviously
I'm a person of faith and the bottom
line for me is I believe God had a
different plan and a purpose for my life
and over the past 20 years I've seen
more evidence of that and and I'm very
secure with that it's God's plan but
aside from that you know I realized that
God never throws you into the fire
without preparing you first
so I spent 20 years in that life at a
very high level and I was a good student
of the life I I observed in our why
and I I reached a certain level there so
I knew I had to make changes you know
one of the horrors about that life and I
don't know if you know this but you
might be in trouble
in serious trouble your best friend
walks you into a room you don't walk out
again and unfortunately I've experienced
that in my life with other people and so
I said okay they're not gonna walk me
into a room they're gonna have to work
to get me I move out of New York I would
have never made it in New York I move
way across the country to California
it's one thing to try to walk somebody
into the room it's another thing to send
a hit squad to try to get somebody who
knows what's going on and I never put a
house in my name no utilities I I never
went to any nightclubs bad place for me
I know who hangs out there somebody sees
me they make a call to New York they
want to be a hero I walk in a parking
lot
boom I'm gone I stop creating patterns
in my life I never went to the same
restaurant every Tuesday night and never
walked my dog every morning at seven
o'clock so if somebody was scoping me
they had a they had a tough time in
figuring out where I was and I was very
disciplined in that very discipline
because I never sell my former
associates short it was very capable
guys there and then what happened
I just outlasted everybody I mean who
went to jail who got killed we had a big
war in our family in the early 90s about
13 guys got killed another 20 or
something went to jail for life and I
just outlasted everybody and you know
the the major thing to me was that I
never testified against anybody I didn't
send anybody to prison I didn't put
anybody in trouble had I done that it
would have been a lot worse
it would have been a lot worse because
some people had personal feelings
against me because when I left you know
look I was making a lot of money a lot
of people were earning with me and when
you shut that off people get upset and
they resented that you know especially
my boss at the time but the fact that he
didn't hurt anybody over a period of
time that really
went my favor and listen you know
there's no guarantees you know I'm still
careful when I go to a certain place
feel feel today oh yeah really
so the level of paranoia is not gone
it's not paranoia and I you know it's
not a macho thing I don't want you to
think that but I just feel very secure
but you know look God doesn't tell you
to be stupid I can't go back to Brooklyn
say hey guys I'm moving back into work
or you know would be like thumbing my
nose at that face so I don't do that but
you know listen I'm a speaker I'm out in
front of thousands of people every week
I've signed books for hundreds of people
I don't know who's on that book line you
know you never know you know I'm not a
kid anymore you know God has blessed me
with with good things in my life and I
think we'll be around for a while longer
but if not I mean what could you do I
mean that's that's how I look at things
it it seems Michael that you're very
result I mean when i when when speaking
to you there's none of it that you're
uncomfortable which is fascinating but
talking about numbers I don't know if
everybody really knows what kind of
numbers you were bringing in the numbers
I read about you were making six to
eight mil awake six to eight million per
week and you were selling a half a
billion dollars of gas per month and
they said you are the highest moneymaker
mafia boss outside of Al Capone I mean
there's a lot of people that are making
money with you how did that happen
people think that mob guys sit around
and they're social clubs and we start to
target different businesses well we're
going to take that over gonna do this
normally doesn't happen that way what
happens is people come to us people
would come to me with all sorts of deals
and it was mostly guys that came inside
their company that had a way to make
some money and they figured they can do
with me I can protect them like a
finance and we have strength you know
all that and that's how this happened in
the gas business some guy came to me at
a very small gasoline operation and he
said you know I have a way to defraud
the government out of tax on every
gallon of gasoline was attractive to me
because at that time I didn't like the
government and you know my targets back
then we're always bigger companies I
didn't go after small the list of
companies they seemed like you didn't go
out there no I didn't go after so I
figure the ones that can afford it nope
and the government was a huge company so
what happened he had a couple of other
wise guys that were kind of trying to
extort him in his business and I was
able to solve that for him and then we
went into business together and I'll
tell you how it happened I I put
somebody with him because I didn't know
him that well and I said I'm gonna put
this fellow with you we're gonna see
exactly what you got going on and we'll
try to figure this out well the guy put
with him was a butcher he was my butcher
big guy at a scar across the top of his
said big Vinny we called him so he's
coming home every Saturday he would
bring meat to my house right so this
Saturday he pulls up and he's got this
big box on his shoulder and I said what
do you do what all that meat it we
having a party or something I don't know
about it he says hey chief at a meet I
said what is it he's to come on in the
kitchen we go in the kitchen he puts the
Box down he opens it up to 180,000
dollars he said that's the first week
steak in the gas business and long story
short he really got my attention at that
point I grew that to 80 into at times
almost eight million dollars a week
bring it her week her woman yeah and
basically you know devised the scheme
built upon what that little germ of an
idea that he had and we were deploying
the government out of tax on every
gallon of gasoline it was 20 to 40 cents
depending where you were located the
government couldn't figure it out we had
a very efficient scheme put together
they just couldn't figure it out we were
always one step ahead it and is this
part of a whole Rico story which was you
know what kind of link to that where
corporation after corporation after
corporation and the last one he would
follow bankruptcy and this this was
figured out on how to avoid paying the
taxes which allowed you to kind of
compete against your marketplace so you
had guys that were buying a million
gallons all of us under buying two three
then they're doing ten million gallons
from you and you're one of the biggest
vendors to them better we would you're
not even middle east don't know from
texas you know you're italian doing this
i had probably three hundred gas
stations we had branded a non branded
stations and what we would do is let's
say it was a mobile station I'm just
picking that out because we dealt with a
show and we go to a station say how much
you paying for a gallon of gas it's not
paying a dollar
now how would you like to pay ninety
five cents a five cents is big saving
boys he said great I said I'll tell you
what you do you how many gallant how
many loads a week you getting from
mobile oh we're getting six all right by
three from them by three from us we'll
deliver in the middle of the night we'll
save you that by the end of the day they
wanted to deliver they wanted us to
service them ball they don't want to buy
anything from Oakland team watch it you
can't do that you got to keep you a
brand nobody can compete with us and if
we bought a couple of gas stations like
I remember one incident there were four
gas stations on the corner big ones we
bought one of them and I went to the
other three and I said now here's the
deal I said I'm gonna be the lowest guy
in a corner I said have yourself a 95
I'm gonna sell for 92
if you sell for 92 I'm gonna go down to
80 until I put you all out of business
so let's keep it at a certain level and
we don't have to compete you told him
that so there was a regulator number
that we're doing with so no one's I said
if you guys stay at this number you'll
be fine
if you try to compete with me I'm gonna
knock you out because you can't compete
with me and pretty soon they were all
buying for me anyway they'll never be
anything like that again I don't know if
I read this right I saw you talk about
it where one of the guys you did
business with was this the oil guy who
for eight years tracked everything that
you were doing who was actually the guy
that ended up becoming the informant
that gave the formation either you know
stop the entire operation yeah he was my
partner he's passed away now we never
had an ill word and seven years that we
were together my kids called him uncle
Larry his kids called me uncle Michael
but the whole time I was its meal ticket
because he knew if he ever got in
trouble that I was a guy that they would
want so he kept a diary on me he
testified against me in one case a big
case would Rudy Giuliani indicted me and
I was acquitted so the jury still didn't
believe them you're making all the
family's money now they're all kind of
happy about you but at the same time you
know you're there as well what happened
when all of a sudden you were growing a
little too fast what kind of threats did
you start seeing at that point where
there's some people that were power
people saying wait a minute I don't like
this guy having this much power yeah you
know what happened I had a couple of
things against me number one I was a
younger guy
and the older guys tend to resent you
you know you're young you're doing all
this you're making all this money and
that comes with the territory can't help
that you try to deal with it as best you
can you know you're not claiming that
fire so to speak but it happens and then
you know I had teamed up with the
Russians I had all the Russian mob guys
in Brighton Beach Brooklyn were all my
partners and they were pretty big crew
and I think it was Newsday publication
out in Long Island had written a story
that I was becoming so powerful I was
gonna break away from the Colombo's and
start my own family no truth to it
whatsoever was like a fairy tale fiction
made up but it got into people's heads
and you know my boss started to
questions some of the Russian guys and
something started to happen like that
and I knew it so I was on my guard about
it you know my father and I discussed it
my dad was always in and out of jail on
parole so when he was out we talked
about these things but I knew I had to
watch myself you know it comes with the
territory
what was the one event that happened
where you're kind of like listen I got a
started taking a look at what's going on
with me was it Joey Columbus story was
at the Castellano which carried it to
him or what was it what you're like
listen I'm gonna start paying a little
bit more attention on what's going on
the marketplace right now you know it
wasn't that it was it was an incident
that I had personally with my boss when
they they basically walked me into that
room and really put me on the hot seat
because there was a story that said that
I would I had stole two billion dollars
from the government and I'm handing the
family two million dollars a week and so
I mean I got questioned you know they
I'm saying two billion dollars Michael I
said hey my answer was when they write
about everybody else it's alive when
they're writing about me all of a sudden
it's the truth I said come on man I'm
giving you guys all this money you don't
have to do anything I'm taking care of
everything you know I put nobody in
trouble nobody's on the line here if
anybody goes down it's going to be me
and my crew I said well what's going on
here you know so I got a little upset
about it and then I was talking to the
boss and you don't lose your head with
the boss but I got Al angry and then I
had a
I'd have told myself down a little bit
you know I did and but that put me on
the alert I said you know I got to
really watch myself here because you
know mistakes here you pay dearly for in
life and I kind of just like I said put
me really on my guard yeah I'll be
honest I thought it was I thought I
might have gotten killed that night you
know did the set up was bad my best
friend was walking me into a room it was
a it was a room in Brooklyn I'll be
honest with ya you know I had a walk out
of the car and into that house and base
that basement apartment it's probably a
30 yard walk that was either the longest
or the shortest welcome oh wow yeah I
mean I as I speak now I can hear the
crickets chirping and I can remember the
smell of the flowers alone because you
know Patrick I learned someone you think
you're gonna meet your maker and I was
in a religious guy at that point you
start to pray and I was I was nervous I
tried not to show it because I said hey
if this is it this is it you kind of get
conditioned to that yes but uh yeah that
was the night and I didn't appreciate it
years later now because you have you
hear stories that your father was
involved and he wasn't involved how do
you feel about that whole situation
where was your dad really kind of saying
let's find out if Michael is really
making this money and I'm not you know
we're not getting a piece of it how did
you respond to that at that time I think
my dad kind of threw me under the bus a
little bit that night he you know he
went in separately and I was told that
he didn't defend me he just kind of
backed off and said hey if my son is
stealing he does everything I don't do
anything I was I'm on parole he handles
everything and knows on bad terms at
that time no we weren't a great term Wow
it really hurt you know because I said
man it kind of gave me really pause
because I said you know if this life can
separate father and son what do we
really have here I never said anything
to him because you know again in that
life you learned to keep things quiet
until you were at the right time and but
it really put me on notice that I got to
really be careful I was very
disappointed in him I didn't it didn't
change my love for him or anything but I
was extremely I was really disappointed
it really hurt how do you from a moment
like that that's it that's a big scar
this is a man that grew up you need to
be a man's man from five years old you
know he's shaping into who you are and
he's coming through
games he's always at your game how do
you from that moment trust anybody else
and not believe that you know at some
moment somebody could turn um is that
the faith part that completely changed
it that brought the peace it did you
know I understand my father I know he's
really a product of that life and I kind
of understood even though I didn't
appreciate it I know my dad still loved
me it wasn't anything like that it's
very hard to explain to anybody else so
I gave my wife has a real problem with
this she says you know you know how do
you forgive that I used to tell her you
don't don't worry about it it's okay and
you know we have this special bond
between us and I understand the life I'm
a product of who but it was still
disappointing because I would have never
done that to him but I'll tell you what
I almost thank him for it now because
I'll tell you this Patrick I met my wife
two years after that and that's when I
made the decision to walk away from that
life but if this innocent incident
didn't happen with my dad I don't think
I would have ever walked away Wow
I think that was God's Way of separating
me from this bond or this hold that my
dad had on me so I could look back and I
said actually it was a good thing
because I don't think I would have
walked away it's amazing how you process
it that way I mean I don't know who can
sit there and go through that and not
think of a different way but the way
you're processing this demand that did
this to give your life maybe a second
chance type of a situation very
interesting so and now he's 100 years
old you know you were telling me you
know he had a surgery recently he's
doing good he's still sharp he thinks
he's gonna live a long time which is
great he still talks to me like I'm part
of that life he's unbelievable he's
little reminiscing and telling old
stories that you remember Michael Oher
yes you know I always say this look my
dad did a lot of rough things in his
life so did I I went to jail for crime
that I was guilty of but you know that
particular crime that he did 38 years in
prison for he was innocent of and I'll
take that to my grave real awe hundred
percent I investigated that case spoke
to every witness they recanted that
testimony
we gave him why detective test proved
they lied at the trial
the FBI was complicit and turning them
against my dad it was a bad case she was
framed thousand percent people say well
you know he got away with so much that's
not how our system supposed to work they
have enough tools and weapons the
government to get people the right way
they're not supposed to do that no
matter what or who you are because
they're they do it against the bad guys
one day they can do it against the good
guys if it suits them so I always say
tell people look you wouldn't want my
dad's life in the last 50 years that man
suffered did 38 years in prison my
sister died of an overdose of drugs
while he was away my brother was a drug
addict my brother actually turned
against my father went into the witness
protection program and testified against
him and got him thrown back in jail my
kid brother I mean my father was
destroyed over there you know my mom
passed away in the last years before she
passed away I can only describe their
relationship as ugly she blamed him for
everything on 33 years without a husband
she blamed him for everything that went
down so I mean the guy's suffered
tremendously and I have a real heart for
that you know I love my dad and we
patched things up you know it's amazing
how you know people said I'd never have
a relationship with him again that you
know when I walked away and God has
brought it full circle and I found out
one thing Patrick you have to give
children or children want to love their
parents you got to give him a real
recent not to love their parents
powerful absolutely I'm just thankful
that we have this relationship again so
Sparks restaurants famous for you know
Paul Castellano is where he got shot
outside by John Gotti and that whole
relationship how was possible Castellano
was he really just a money business guy
I knew Paul I didn't know him well
because she was a boss I was young at
that time but I was in his company quite
a bit and I did have an incident with
him and quite honestly you know the word
on him on the street was not great
think he had a lot of real friends on
the streets especially any other
families I know in our family they
didn't talk well about him more of a
business guy you know that kind of a
thing I think people think that maybe he
didn't earn the position that he had
because he was so close to Carlo and
carlo gave him that spot you know it
went down with Gotti I mean it was it
was either him or Gotti at that point
and John made the move and you know in
our life there's no election process you
know if you're gonna take over you're
gonna take over the hard way
you don't rival a boss and look for
votes you rival a boss by eliminating
you know look money is always at the
root of just about everything there you
know if you were good you make people
earn people like you that's the bottom
line you know and if they don't like it
they'll tolerate you because you're
earning with them but he was kind of
known to be a greedy guy and he didn't
fit the the profile of the real mob boss
in a way you know god he doesn't make
that move on his own he kind of solicits
people hey what do you think he tries to
get some support that if this would have
happened you know how are people gonna
react so he kind of knew how it was
gonna work out if he took him out every
time you had to running with them you've
had obviously many run-ins with them
you've done a couple sit downs with them
how was God he like personality-wise why
did he have this you know larger than
life story the nowhere near the kind of
money you brought him what made him that
special well you know he was he fit the
Hollywood profile so to speak and he had
the look you had the mannerisms you know
one thing I will say about John I happen
to like him
you know socially a lot of fun we were
going a club gave me a lot of fun and he
was a good guy to be around business he
didn't really understand business and
and it was a nightmare dealing with him
in that respect because one thing about
Gotti in his mind he always tried to
come out on top he can never be a loser
never so it's very hard to negotiate and
do anything you had to make him think
that he won even if you were winning it
was the only way to get around and get
something at him so you had to kind of
have that mentality going in with him
but I was very difficult to deal with in
that regard I respected him because he
made no bones about who he was yeah I'm
a gangster I'm a mobster I love this
thing
that's all I am and that's all I ever
wanted
and it was public about that it was
public about it and that was it you know
people say he destroyed the life he
didn't destroy the life you know I mean
we all destroyed the life you know the
government just won up to us with their
technology with the laws with the
informants they had I remember reading
this what you said when you went to
prison they didn't bother you when he
went to prison he got bullied in prison
my father taught me something it should
Mike when you go into prison remember
three things three words that are gonna
take you make you have an easy go of it
with other guys remember to say please
thank you and excuse me you know because
you bump into somebody excuse me you
know yes somebody please may I have this
you don't cut in front of people on a
line because everybody that so many guys
rather I should say that got no respect
on the street want to get all the
respect in there because they're putting
on a show for everybody else so little
silly things become major things you got
it so you can't throw your weight around
now you can't take any nonsense but you
know people have to understand you may
be the silent type but don't mess with
me and I'm not going to disrespect you
don't disrespect me and John carried
himself differently paid the price and I
know a few guys that did the attack so
business you wrote this book I'll make
you an offer you can't refuse
when I read books you know leave my mark
and write down I made so many marks in
this that was just in it's a it's a
small book you know what I'm amazed I
will tell you if you haven't read this
book you have to read this book it was
in oh 9 which social media wasn't around
I hope we can make this book become a
phenomenon because I think every
entrepreneur salesperson leader must
read this book so make a list of it
we'll put a link on the bottom for you
to get as well you linked it between
business and the Mafia life that you
went through and you talked a lot of a
lot of different parts of it tell me
about the sit down which was obviously
very big in the in the business you were
in and sit down to us maybe we go into a
boardroom and you know we're Center
negotiating with our investors or you
know you know Advisory Board whatever it
is how was sit down like for you guys
well it was it was the basis or the the
format in which
he resolved everything I mean anytime we
had a resolve a business dispute
something more serious we did it at a
sit-down as we called it it's funny
because my publisher after they read
that chapter they don't have any more
meetings then the whole place doesn't
sit down
these were high-level very sophisticated
meetings believe it or not and we had
certain rules you know if you're a made
guy and you're at a sit-down you had to
be respectful no matter what the
situation was in other words if I'm a
made guy and I'm arguing something and
I'm lying and you know I'm lying you
can't call me a liar have you call me a
liar you lose the argument automatically
you have to figure out a way to make
people know that you're wrong that this
guy is wrong and I'm right and the old
time was very tactful at this you know
they would try to get you into a trap or
you would just say something and you're
done it's all over so you had to really
learn how to respectfully get your point
across and you had to know the mentality
of the personality of the person going
in well you don't defeat him these
old-timers were smart you know they were
cagey I had so many of these because it
was like every day in my life when I was
in the gas business I had somebody
trying to take over somebody trying to
get in cuz you know in New York there's
a lot of us and we were constantly
engaging with one another on different
matters and I had a big crew so the guys
are my crew got in trouble at it sit
down one other bit was constant business
so you learn how to carry yourself there
and it really helped me in my
negotiation skills in business it really
helped because going in I would figure
out what I wanted what I would settle
for and I would keep you know I learned
one thing it's always great to let the
other person talk let them talk let them
just keep talking throw out a word that
gets from a little bit and he'll talk
more and as he's talking you can kind of
figure out his mentality as personality
what you can get out of them what you
can't get out of them and it helped me a
lot in negotiating deals later on
and you know sometimes you may be the
smartest person in the room and you
don't want anybody to know that you just
want to keep quiet like you don't know
anything let them think they're smarter
than you and there's other times when
you're not the smartest person in the
room but you want people to think you
are so you have to learn how to have
that skill were you a big reader because
what you just said is art of war right
so you know when you're strong you know
you got to show that you're weak when
you're weak you got to act strong so
were you one that's I mean obviously I
you read Machiavelli Prince that was
kind of the Bible for the family right
but were you always reading no I wasn't
a big reader honestly I became a reader
in prison did I have a lot to do but no
it's just something I developed I think
along the way one real talent that
helped me a skill or two number one I
recognized a good deal because I got a
lot of stuff thrown at me and I
recognized what was good and what wasn't
going to work and that's important
because you can waste your time with
stuff all day long and secondly was I
always say I knew how to put the right
people in the right place and get them
and motivated them to do the work
properly
my mantra always was at that time do
what you do best and delegate the rest
and then make sure they do the job and
that always worked for me until today
you know those things that I'm just not
good at and I don't even try to do them
I don't want to be bothered with it but
I'll get somebody's gonna do them said a
whole lot better
oh yeah yeah I had to so who was the
best guy you saw to sit down were you
every time you went there you know he
was gonna be able to sit down you either
learned a lot from him or you knew this
was not gonna be an easy one yeah well
God he was tough I mean you know you
knew going in you had just outsmart him
and let him think he want but you get
out of there with what you really oh
yeah Wow
yeah you know I had to deal with him
long story showed me sounds silly but it
wasn't at the time we had a big flea
market a swap meet and there were two
partners there one of them was an
accountant legitimate guy and he was my
guy and there was another guy that he
was partners with that was kind of a
street guy and they couldn't get along
and the kid was stealing out of the
market so the guy came to me so I threw
the kid out of them
I said you can't come back you're done
we're taking it over well he runs to
John and John says he gets in touch with
me smite this kid belongs to me and half
the market his mind I said John the guy
didn't even know who you were he ran to
you now all of a sudden you know him
your whole life you know that's what
happens in that life so I have a big sit
down and we can't get along and I said I
told my guys that you're never gonna get
along with this guy and I'm never gonna
get along with John in this market I
said so we have to do something either
we're gonna buy him out or he's gonna
buy us and so I knew at the time that he
would never stand for me buying him out
never pride
yeah pride so I had to I had to have him
buy me out but if I told to buy me out
he wouldn't buy me out so I went in
there and we sat down it said John I'm
buying you out and the first words it's
like I know he's you don't buy me out I
bought you out I said no I'm buying yeah
we impact report finally I gave in and
said I buy me out
you know so he buys me out you know we
get out we share the money or whatever
three months later the market went down
it closed because I knew what they were
gonna do now who got the better end of
the deal
I don't know cuz I know what I got who
knows how much he got what he busted the
market out but it worked out better that
way but you know he thought he won you
know he could tell everybody he got me
out of the market and meanwhile I got
what I wanted so that's how you had to
deal with him very interesting anybody
else that was very good to sit down that
was a different approach than him you
know I sat down with Castellano he was
rough you know he was small business but
you know he's a boss so he can throw his
weight around a little bit more and you
had to be mindful of that you know but
you had to be respectful and just hold
your ground you know and but he was good
it was really good i sat down with Fat
Tony Salerno was the boss of the
Genovese family I like Tony a lot you
know I really like to really respected
him he was very good the old time was
good younger guys not so much but you
know I had an advantage I mean oh he
said my father you know early on was my
mentor so he kind of he kind of gave me
clues as to how to how to go in and win
and he was good 35 it's like you were
the LeBron James of the era right I mean
you were the youngest guy I mean it's 11
years is the difference to the
second-youngest guy and that's God
you're doing it at 35 sitting with these
powerful guys negotiating Michael how
was compensation figured out okay 40
cents I'm bringing a half a billion
gallons six to eight million a week how
was the money spread so the soldiers you
know and then you got how was that sprut
is was there a arrangement that was
everyone knew how the numbers will be at
ten percent you were five percent or 20
percent here or would everything vary
and nothing was really a steady number
that would always be there I had my own
formula and I discussed it with my
father and we came to this conclusion if
it was it was legitimate deal I didn't
have to give anybody anything was my
deal like I had a couple of automobile
dealerships I had a movie I had a lot of
stuff legitimately
that was mine so if you if you started
and nobody else helped you start it's
100% youit's mine and you don't have to
share any of it no unless I took him in
as a pawn it gave me money it got ever
no it was totally my God my legit stuff
was mine the street stuff was different
like when I when I first got involved
with the gas business and I knew what I
had I want to see my boss I said to him
I said jr. I'm on to something this
Persico I said I'm gonna show you more
money than you ever seen before and he
said we don't do drugs I says not drugs
you know I'm not into that
I said I'm into the gas business I said
but here's the deal I don't need you to
do anything but when other families
learn of what we have everybody's gonna
want to get involved I said as soon as
that happens we're gonna blow it I said
you got to keep this within the family I
said if we have an argument you got to
make me win you got to make me win don't
play politics nothing you do that for me
and I'll show you more money than you
ever saw before and he said show me and
I'm starting to bring him every week all
you had to do was sit back and ask him
for anything right but every time we had
to sit down I had to win now I'm
bringing him two million dollars a week
that buys a lot of loyalty and my
formula was if I brought the deal in and
I didn't need anything from you you got
25% of anything
25% goes back to the family got it if I
needed you in some way like
money from you or whatever that was
different than when maybe you know maybe
you have my full partner Elliott
everything was there was a 25% / 25% was
my deal and I was a captain so there was
nobody between me and God so I gave it
to him like if I was a soldier I'd have
to give it to my captain my captain they
would give it to him and they'd work it
out once you're a captain you only
report up right there's nobody directly
to the boss
you talked about conciliar ii right
counselor
I can tell you I am where I'm at right
now because I've had some amazing
advisors in my life I can't even we're
talking my deadly earlier we were talk
my certain you know Tom and some of
these other guys that have affected my
life how do you know who is a console
area where you can open up with like in
your world that's a big part of your
life in your business so how do you
identify one and when do you know this
is gonna be the guy that I'm gonna go to
the console area is an official position
in our life there was a coroner made man
or four there's one console area in
every family and the console era his
official position is that he is the
liaison between the men and the boss in
other words in that life we told this
everybody is equal you may be the boss
but you're still equal you don't have
better rights than the soldier we're all
made guys we're all equal you just
happen to have a different position
you're in control but we're equal you
can't you can't violate a soldier's
right either so if a soldier has a
problem maybe with the boss or something
he's supposed to go to the console area
and the console area straightens it out
with the boss that's in theory how it is
in practice it doesn't work that way
because the boss appoints the console
area and if you have a problem with the
boss and you go to the console area
you're probably going to get killed or
get in trouble so you never said
anything to the console here it was kind
of a nonsense position you know and
usually it was it was a guy that the
boss respected that you know he would
want things off of and they discuss
things together and figure out what they
have to do in any situation you didn't
have an individual concierge but I
obviously the guy that I trusted the
most and talked with was my dad if I had
something that I thought I needed advice
would I talk
was it it's good to have that one person
there that you could go to and say look
you know especially my dad cause he knew
the life shoulder so well what made a
very good conciliate so if you were to
say here's what makes a very good
conciliate what would you say it was
wisdom he had to know the life he had to
have good discernment you know uh you
know how to figure things out he should
be a cool tempered guy and he should be
sincere you know and not have his own
personal agenda that's important but
that's rare telling it's rare in that
life there's so much politics that goes
on there you really had to be careful
what was the benefit of being a
considering it's a high position you
know it's it's I mean the underboss in
the console area we're kind of equal
really really Wow
so that that much of a respected
position so let's transition to human
nature you know what were what were some
of the things that you learned where you
would go and have a sit-down or you meet
with people and you would say I don't
know if I feel comfortable with this guy
I don't know if I trust this guy I feel
comfortable trust in this guy was there
a methodology that you eventually put
together or was it still an intuition
type of thing when you were reading
people it was more intuitive I would say
because everybody was so different
obviously if you had experience with
somebody more than once then you know
all right I know I'm up I'm in four with
this guy but it was more intuitive
because again with me I had so many you
know with so many different people and
III pretty well knew you know when you
you start to get some experience in that
life you know right away you know when
somebody's out to get you and so to
speak you know they're looking to you
know not make things turn out for you
well you know you just deal with it
because that would have some probably a
person who ends up becoming a boss in
that world you have to be very good in
human nature you know you've got to be
able to figure it out and see who's even
if you have a sit down you're sinner
you're looking at this guy saying that
guy's not on my side this guy's on my
said that guy's in the middle this guy
there was a lot of that probably going
on all the time yeah you know you know
the problem though Patrick with that
life
that life is like it's like a wheel
turning around and the guy that's on the
bottom today can end up being on the top
tomorrow and you always had to be
mindful of that
so for instance you know in Gatti's case
you know he could add a soldier close to
him that was nobody really and then all
of a sudden God he's the boss and how
this guy becomes somebody so a guy that
you didn't have much respect for now you
better respect God so because of that
you always tried to treat people the way
yeah there is you never know you know
where that guy's gonna be the next day
or the next week and then he's got it in
for you and then you got a problem that
is that is very interesting when you
think about that because that guy comes
up the influence is gonna be with him
right so let's transition into some
interesting character so Rudy Guiliani
right he keeps coming up right and he
wants to clean house as you want is what
he wants to do Rudy says a guy who wrote
a book man of honor Marathon Man on on
who's the person they're on oh okay so
he writes the book and then he gives the
blueprint to them to know what the rico
game was and he puts that together and
they had the best FBI agent at that time
some guy named Linda Lee or Lin you know
that he know how to go and create an
informants and he goes and figures out
with the Green Reaper the Scarpa I think
so how is that really truth to it
anymore okay
don't believe any of that I mean
Giuliani says that the reason he he was
in he had a position in Washington DC in
the Department of Justice and his story
was that Joe Bonanno wrote this book and
he being an italian-american Giuliani
was so insulted by this book because he
made the Mafia out to be like a family
like it was a very legitimate great
thing and he wasn't so insulted by a
Giuliani that he had a clean house
because of it and that's why he came to
New York and became the US Attorney
there so he could attack the mob and
clean house
I don't know if I believe that I think
he was an opportunistic guy and being a
US attorney in Manhattan is an extremely
prestigious position and he picked our
guys to go after and build his career at
that point in time and he did a great
job of it I mean let's face it he has
that repetition till today yeah I mean
he was very capable at what he did the
racketeering the RICO statute had been
on the books for over ten years when
Rudy came in but nobody ever used it
he learned or he saw how to use it
effectively and he started using it
against us and it was designed to be
used against us but nobody ever did it
and it's an it's extremely difficult law
to to navigate around I mean I had three
recon diagnosed to me I mean I think
it's an unconstitutional law but it's a
law and nevertheless it's on the books
so you live with it but uh you know he
just was determined to make his name on
us guys and he did did you ever have a
one-on-one running with them I had one
if one in the courtroom the day I was he
indicted me on a big RICO case and the
day of my arraignment I had he was
giving me bail and he came up to me and
he said Francis if I convict you on this
case I'm gonna give you double what your
father got you gotta get a hundred years
and that's the kind of time they'll give
it told me straight out and I said Rudy
I beat you guys three times already
let's go for round four I told him you
know it's kind of arrogant back then but
uh you know I was on trial for several
months and I was as a lead defendant and
I was acquitted in that case some of my
code events are convicted I got 30 years
so he I would have probably got at least
50 if I lose that case so to say that I
won that case was a blessing as an
understand why I'd still be in prison
Wow
what do you think about Rudy today what
do you feel like when you see Rudy today
on TV I mean some news was on so when
you watch TV and you see him what how do
you how do you look at him when you you
know I know I'm okay with him I mean
it's not personal you know I actually
saw him one time he actually he said
some good things about me later on
because when I was walking away from
that life most of people and governments
that adds a fraud
he's not really walking away and he's
pulling a scam off the government like
he didn't a gas business everybody said
that but Rudy said you know what he's
pretty smart guy and he knows this life
is on the run and I think his walking
away may be genuine
he said that early on when you're with
you was it was in the night yeah it was
yeah I was in the it was in the early
90s yeah he came and he said that there
interesting for him to say but listen
he's a very capable guy no question
about it I will tell you this I thought
it was a great mayor in New York yeah
really did he did a lot for that city
without a doubt so I mean I can't knock
his you know his abilities he was he was
good at what he did he says a big part
of it was something about his dad you
know and his dad said we can't be
bullied in New York and that was his
inspiration which I'm like wow wouldn't
what a thing to remember for your dad to
instill there you get down much and
drive to want to go against the five
families that's that that's got to be a
chip on his shoulder to want to do
something no I mean it's a good
narrative but if you're gonna make your
name in New York you're gonna make it
two ways you're going after Wall Street
are you going after the mob that's it
and he chose both let's face it I mean
he got Boesky and he got what's his name
on the other big guy oh my gosh forget
Milken you got Milliken and he got us he
got us all so I mean you know but I'll
tell you what I owe a lot to him and he
doesn't even realize this when I was on
trial I ERISA my guest business partner
had become an informant they were
creating the case against me in the gas
business and I ERISA was the star
witness
well when Giuliani found out that they
had this big witness against me and I
was on trial he wanted that witness to
testify against me the problem was I
arezzo didn't really know anything about
that case but there was a big dispute I
found out afterwards between East and
district and Giuliani over getting iya
Rizzo to testify because the Eastern
District didn't want to give him up that
was their guy you know it is the
government anyhow Giuliani's got a lot
of juice he wins we put I original on
the stand okay
and we crucify him up there destroyed
him on the stand
okay jury didn't believe might get
acquitted what happens now
now the government is scared because I
just beat their main witness against me
in the gas case they're ready to throw
him out of the witness protection for a
while that's what gave me the leverage
to negotiate the deal that I got because
they were afraid I was going to beat him
again because I had won four cases now I
know they called John a Teflon Don but
I've won four cases two and and the
Giuliani case was a big loss for them
and if you look back that was the only
case that ended up in an acquittal he
convicted everybody we were the only
ones whether it was an acquittal so that
gave me the leverage to go in and make
the deal in Eastern District and only I
say only get ten years because that was
a bonus back then only get ten years
they were given everybody 50 and on you
got ten I got ten that's amazing
compared to some of the other stories
you hear about I'll tell you this I
believe if I resident testifying the
Giuliani keishon I beat him yeah they
wouldn't have made to deal with me they
would have taken me to trial because it
was the gas business they figured they
had me wow you're gonna put me away
forever but they got scared how much
would you have gone third thirty five
fifty it was all easy easy
fifty minimum really yeah Patrick they
were given guys a hundred one hundred
and fifty years Wow and I'm since I'm
the youngest that already you're not
gonna go on a three hundred years
unbelievable they would have crucified
me when you have time to think and
really analyze the way life go and you
look back and I said man all these
negatives turned into a positive for me
they gave me breaks that I didn't
realize were happening at that time you
know it's a big part of my faith when I
talk to people I said you know that the
misery that you're going through now
might be the blessing for you later on I
said it happened in my life in more than
one situation you know my father
okay betraying me that later broke that
tie that got me out of that life because
everybody I know either dead or in
prison for the rest of their lives
everybody so how is that gonna walk well
I had a major bull's-eye on my back they
weren't gonna let me go
no way is unbelievable story right there
like by itself that's an unbelievable
story so Rudy Guiliani you know will be
fun
it'd be fun to be at a sit-down with you
Rudy and just hearing the conversations
now you're what huh I would love first
thing I tell Rudy no the I'm the only
got it beat you yeah I started off like
that put him right on it so let some
characters you know couple characters
that I'm curious about if you ever had a
running with did you ever have any
business with Roy :
I did how how was its personality
because you hear Roy Cohen the influence
would trump and you know he was working
with the five families and everybody
trusted him because he wasn't leaking
any information to anybody you know the
story that he had in the court many
years ago that you read about all the
time so who how was Roy :
he was respected if I'll tell my major
Roy Cohn incident I get indicted in the
Giuliani case Roy reaches out to me go
to his office I go see him he said I
heard about the case he says I didn't
get your indictment squashed a Patrick
nobody gets an indictment squash not in
the federal level not when you're a
target like me I said okay I just what
do you want
he said I won 250 grand he says and I'll
make it go away I said I'll tell you
what I said I'm calculating I got to go
to trial this and that I lose you know
I'm gonna go I said
I'll put a million dollars in escrow
okay when the indictment is squash take
the whole million because I knew it
wasn't it happening he's well you know
it doesn't work that way
I say look that's how I work it I so I'm
giving you four three times in my four
times the money I said I'm putting in
escrow take it squash the indictment you
got it that was the end of that it's
trying to beat me yeah you know because
then they come up with another issue
that's right says and we never trusted
our lawyers never try even the lives
even ones we loved we ate it well you
know you got he apparently had a great
lawyer but you Scott you know I'm
talking every scholar I knew Bruce well
was he so he also people didn't trust
them either you trust him to a point
right cuz it's money it's my fees per
hour and the whole you never you never
ever ever admit it to your lawyer no
matter how much you trust him that you
were guilty was Roy trusted no really no
seriously he was yeah let me tell you
something about their life and I don't
mean this to be anybody that wasn't a
made guy it could have been the
president United States or the Pope if
you're not a made guy you're a sucker
everybody was on the same level and Roy
Cohn if you could use him you used him
what did we trust him hell no Bruce
Cutler we're using everything else but
you don't trust them 100% I mean that's
just the way we dealt with them
that makes sense so was Joey Gallo
really the guide that you know that
killed you know
Joe Joey Gallo was the guy that did it
was a thousand hated it wasn't him
personally so of course he had the yeah
but he was behind that yeah that was
verified everybody knew that it was was
Nicky black as feared of a man as they
paint him out to be no okay no I got
along well with Nicky I tell you one
story though I went into his he had a
bar and he was brutal guy I gotta tell
you and some guy owed him money and I
went in the back with him he's Nick
might come over here and he was breaking
the guys hands and everything like that
I got all the money
you know and I said Nicky come on man
you know I said I was a guy gonna pay if
you break his hands can't even go to
work you know after you know but but no
he wasn't
you gotta you gotta understand something
to you know bond John Gotti was feared
by everybody John talked a lot but we
all were capable of doing what we had to
do you know we we were only in fear if
we did something wrong and we knew we
had to be afraid but because you throw
your chest out you're no more capable
than I am in other words if I if I got
an order to kill you I'm gonna kill you
I don't care who you are I have to
otherwise my life is at stake so we
didn't fear people in that way but you
know there's people you don't want to
cause like jr. my boss he was a
treacherous guy I don't want to cross
him because I
know what's gonna happen that bad I mean
you're like--you're you read about him
is like they call him the snake I mean
he was he was a treacherous guy I mean I
liked him don't get me wrong I got along
with him but I knew I knew not to mess
with him so we all had that kind of a
fear you know what I mean don't don't
mess because you may walk in a room and
not walk out what made Capone special
you know and in the community was it
anything significant that because they
put you in Capone in the same league for
the most money made right so listen what
they always said and I believe it to be
that the guest business was the most
money that we had seen since the days of
prohibition
now we're not adjusting for inflation
sir but so I mean he was an earner he
had he caught it lucky like I did I
guess you know I found the gas tax at
that time there was prohibition and he
he found the right deal and he was able
to capitalize on it so when it comes
down to sports do you think you know the
whole P pros story and all these things
you hear about back in the days okay
you think a lot of it still happens
today as far as as far as hey make sure
you don't win by 11:00 you know make
sure you you know don't pitch the game
like this you do this I know what
happens a lot in a high school in the
college level do you think it still
happens at the highest level in the pros
I don't believe so because the salaries
now that these guys make you know they
can afford to lose they'll pay their
bets
they'll pay their debts you know back in
my day was different story
you know I bookmakers working for me and
we had a lot of athletes gambling with
us and I remember bookmakers calling me
up hey Mike so-and-so is into me for 25
grand should I cut him off I said why
would you cut him off
all you're doing is writing an entry on
a piece of paper I said get leverage let
him get into you for 250 grand and then
bring him to me the higher the loss the
more leverage you got over together you
know because they didn't have that kind
of money back then now 250 grand it paid
off what's the big deal nothing no let
me look Michael Jordan is a legendary
degenerate gambler and I'm not calling
him personally I've just called his
gambling sure sure yeah the guy can lose
a million dollars a week and one face
yeah you know show I mean there's Kant
and there's some controversy behind him
with the whole what happened to his dad
do you remember that whole thing but was
it was it not in and Stern told him to
step away but I mean I don't know the
story behind it but III definitely
believe because I was working with the
NBA at that point in time and they told
him to get away that's really when you
definitely believe 100% I believe that
and he went and played baseball for a
year just to get let things die down and
then he came back you know yeah I mean
that's that was the inside talk at that
time I read both sides and I'm like you
know it's kind of convincing I just
don't know for me to say that but you
hear some high credible sources saying
that you know that this took place last
few things here before we wrap up so you
got a new project coming up I literally
got an email a week ago I said hey did
you know Michael got casted for a movie
with Tom Hanks and you know with
Katarina radivoje average from you know
Croatia or you know the movie is gonna
be in Croatia it's a 50 million dollar
budget this all of a sudden you know I
had a movie I had a role in a movie
recently called let there be light with
Kevin Sorbo and the long story short how
that happened the writer is a good
friend of mine he roped me into the and
then he said Mike I want you to play the
part I had no intention of doing it but
I ended up doing it was an ex-mob guy
who became a pastor big stretch big
stretch for me right those but basically
playing myself but you know I'm involved
with a fella by name of Tom Creole and
Tom is he goes after black money black
money meaning money that's used to
finance terrorist groups and money
that's used to go after Christian you
know martyrs I mean to moderate
Christians and he and I kind of working
together and he's he created a film a a
game rather called gosh I forget Eavis
something a game right and they're
creating a movie out of the game and I
think they spoke to Tom Hanks and he
wants to be in it
let me tell you about this movies it's
it's a it's an early project so who
knows if it'll ever come to pass but yes
they want me to play the role and I said
look because of the cause I'll be
involved with and I'm not an actor I
don't
tend to be an actor but I guess if the
right thing comes up and it works for
you do it so I do know that you had some
experience with movies in the past that
you you know had somebody that work with
you that you know you funded some movies
a quarter-million dollars that led to
another half a million dollars so there
are some stories about what are you
working on nowadays what are some
projects you're working on nowadays a
couple of things are real exciting hi my
main project right now is I'm doing a
stage show in Las Vegas and it's the
history of the mob in Las Vegas set to
music and dance it's a musical Wow and
we're telling the whole history of the
mob from the 1950s okay when they got
involved and actually created Vegas
right through the 80s when they kind of
were pushed out and I'm gonna narrate it
actually on stage and a little bit of my
story's gonna be interspersed in that
the way we've designed it but it's a
really cool project I'm very excited
about it's gonna appear at the Plaza
downtown we have a marketing arrangement
with the mob museum that's a that's a
big museum downtown and now Vegas have a
relationship with them there and it's
going to premiere in May of next year so
I have that and I've got two television
projects one is a scripted series called
American royalty and that is the history
of the mob in New York from the 50s
right through the mid 70s and we're
going to tell the story of the five
families and I'm really excited about
the project cuz I'm with a great company
and they put together a great showrunner
and writer which got you know tremendous
credits and I think that's going to go
next year and I'm doing a true-crime
unscripted show that's called a mafia
democracy and basically the theme of the
show is that we're going to highlight
cases where the government was complicit
in framing somebody
we're gonna be holding the government
accountable in cases like that the first
case that we're gonna highlight in the
first season is my father's case why
we're gonna tell that whole story on
believing in six episodes does he know
about it he does and I said to him dad
for 50 years you've been complaining
that you've been framed
I believe you a lot of people believe
you but you never want to talk about it
on camera I said I'm gonna do this show
I said but you have to get on camera and
all you have to say is I was framed I'm
gonna ask you some questions and you got
to cooperate you know what he says to me
these let me ask my lawyer I said dad
you don't have a lawyer I gave you a
lawyer I said your lawyers gonna say yes
so you got to commit to me that you're
going to do it so he committed he said
yes that's cool he's never been on count
my dad has never said a word to the
press has never been interviewed so this
would be the first time the oldest made
guy in America okay is finally gonna be
on camera and say some things and I said
you don't have to admit who you are what
you did or what you were involved in I'm
gonna get him to do that anyway but uh
yeah he's agreed I think it's important
you know again I want people understand
I'm not anti-government I'm not anti
law-enforcement I have many friends in
law enforcement I have brothers in
Christ in full enforcement and I'd tell
people I have five daughters when they
walk down the street I expect law
enforcement so heck down yeah I'm a
friend to law enforcement but what I
don't like is when they go rogue and
they frame people and they put people
who are in they destroy lives they have
enough weapons and tools to play by the
rules and go again and go and get people
the right way and most good people in
law enforcement feel the same way so I'm
not you know I'm not going against them
but to me it's an exciting series it's
kind of like you know John Walsh in
America's Most Wanted he had a personal
stake in this and I'm gonna host that
series it looks like they want me to do
that and hopefully that'll be a success
and I'll have the right impact and I be
honest reap a drag I don't think there's
ever been a time in my lifetime where a
show like this would be more relevant
and dealing with government is not great
I know it's not no it's not and you kind
of talked about in the end of your book
you know if there's anything I would say
when you buy the book I'll make you an
offer you can refuse the last chapter
really gets into your beliefs about the
government and politics and all that
which I think it's very fascinating
maybe we can talk about that on another
time but guys again if you haven't read
the book go buy the book we'll put a
link on the bottom Michael thank you so
much for opening thank you what a tree
appreciation thank you